[Music]
oh
[Music]
i'm going to take some quick break for
about 10 minutes i'm just gonna just
like stretch a little bit and then go
back to work for another 40 minutes and
then at seven o'clock i'll have
breakfast
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
here
[Music]
i'm in my third year at exeter medical
school and if you'd like to see a bit
more of my life feel free to subscribe
and follow me on instagram which i will
put somewhere here so currently i'm in
my orthopedics week which is bones and
joints and i'm going to be in the
hospital at 8 00 8 15 a.m so we have a
very early morning so i need to leave
very soon actually because the time is
10 to 8 at this moment
so yeah i'll see you in the hospital
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there has been some changes to the plan
so originally i'm supposed to be in the
ward round at the moment but i'm in the
library and the time is 23 past 10
because we had a one half hour long
orthopedics handover before the ward
round but at the end of the handover the
consultant said that he was only happy
to have one medical student with them
for the world realms so me and my
placement partner had to sacrifice and
go somewhere else the priya is in the
fracture clinic right now and i'll be
going into trauma theater to see a
intramedullary nail fixation of the
femur most of the time the consultant
won't be able to accommodate yourself
and all of your placement partners so
you will have to separate and this is
part of medical student life really
still have around an hour left until the
theatre starts until then i'll do some
work in the library
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
introduce yourself
well this is our house this is what we
eat as a medical student
tell us what you've been up to today as
a third year medical student
recently got back from gp placement we
had our cbd that's case based discussion
so we've got our patient on tuesday you
take history from them write it all down
go home and then
do research on it especially on the
differentials and then we present it
back to the gp or consultant when it's
in the hospital and we tell them what we
found in our history what we found in
examination if there are any
investigations that were done but we
think the next steps should be it's like
practicing to be a doctor you will
report back to the consultant tell them
what you think the patient has tell them
what you want to do next so we're
practicing that basically that's what
i've done today
and now i'm eating lunch and then i'll
go to the gym
what you've been up to today
i am about to head to the library to do
some cbd
hi tim hello
what you been up to today i prepared the
cvd
everyone is talking about cvd today
what about you what's your plan for the
afternoon moja's going to the library
but what about you
into med school
nice
[Music]
so another update in the end the the
femur operation delayed until 2 pm due
to over running of the previous surgery
it was supposed to first start at 11 a.m
because it delayed until 2 p.m in
between i did go to clinical skills to
practice on my cannulation then i went
home to have some fruit as lunch because
i didn't have much time then i went back
to the operating theatres to see that
operation that has finished around 5-ish
so i was home around 5 00 p.m currently
it's 20 past seven so in between i made
dinner and also i chatted with my
flatmates
so from now on to half past nine i will
do some work for my cbd on friday and
after that i'm going to go to bed so i'm
actually aiming to go to bed around half
past nine because i have an early
morning tomorrow as well i'm hoping to
actually go on the ward round tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
you